[Aplausos]
botar todos o que queria começar dizendo
que foi para mim um enorme prazer
receber este convite para participar
aqui como era do ouro na 1ª t rex do
funchal
o próprio tema o espírito é algo com que
me identifico fundamento
eu acredito que o homem para 13 em
sumidouro inovador criativo
o evento é muito pode faltar às vezes um
período do dia
conseguimos fazer com o nosso mundo
público avança pra mim é óbvio que eu
queria aceitar esse convite
estar aqui hoje com vocês cortaram minha
história nem ilha com níger seria mesmo
um orgulho mas o contrato possa imaginar
tomar essa decisão há uns meses atrás
no fim nada fácil é verdade que minha
mulher está grávida e vamos ter um bebê
e ela já pessoa como além das 37 semanas
e portanto se por um lado e cria caspar
principado por outro não credito perder
aquilo que é um evento único na minha
vida que é acompanhar o crescimento do
meu primeiro filho uma menina que fazer
é trabalhar o quadro qualquer a
probabilidade de minha mulher entrar em
trabalho de parto e até o dia de hoje
então é seguir uma distribuição normal
como e meio de gravidez 40 semanas 15
padrão dez dias apenas 2% das mulheres
em trabalho parte das 37 semanas e
probabilidade de ela ter hoje nosso bebê
é de apenas de cerca de 6%
eu estava contente estes números são
bastante animadores
eu estava disposto a assumir esse risco
e estar aqui presente hoje com vocês não
imaginam que ter essa conversa com uma
mulher grávida
eulina é divulgava ela gosta de
matemática como eu gosto era comum aos
tribunais
[Aplausos]
ela foi muito paciente e houve o mesmo
tranquilamente não hesitou em exercer o
seu direito ao contraditório
ela invocou uma wii a qual isso muito
sensível
além do marfim não querem mais trabalho
fiz uma análise de risco e de um plano
de contingência que estou aqui hoje como
uma nova ligada como turista a porta a
uma nova e um cartão visa pronto a
seguir daqui isto é a vida toda a gente
nós estamos constantemente fim na
prática o que a nossa vida e temos que
correr riscos temos que seguir as nossas
paixões as nossas emoções e esperar e
fazer tudo para obter os resultados e
fiz o que fiz durante toda a minha vida
também mais em tirava 21 foto tirada há
21 anos atrás era finalista aqui na
madeira era um jovem sentindo capaz de
tudo estava pronto quando marilyn água
marítima do céu
o objetivo era ser piloto de caça da
força aérea que gostava de ser piloto
minha avó paterna tem tinha uma casa com
vista privilegiada do aeroporto e não
importava de ver os aviões aterraram
hoje à tarde seria uma das pistas mais
difíceis na europa nessa altura e só os
melhores pilotos em um para tratar aqui
agora e eu penso que seja esse desafio
essa dificuldade acrescida que fazia com
que esta não conseguir fazer aqui vai
concorrer à força aérea e eu e mais mil
candidatos para ser vagas
eu falava que ao fim de três dias de
testes e exames médicos e foi excluída
a descoberta é que eu via que tinha
falta de vista e que não podia seguir o
meu sonho de sempre
não posso mentir fiquei devastado e
voltar à ilha é pensar o que eu vou
fazer da vida
nunca tinha um olhar a lista de cursos
do ensino superior
o primeiro havia dúvidas e aprovada
também não foi difícil escolher
eu acho que o livro faça esse ponto não
é esse piloto ia construir aviões de
concorrer às duas vagas nos cursos
existentes em portugal um deus
a primeira opção foi para o técnico em
engenharia aeroespacial segunda opção
engenharia aeronáutica no hub
entrei na primeira opção como nota da
turma e conseguir o técnico deparam com
um outro ou tristeza porque vi toda a
gente à minha volta é dizer que éramos
malucos engenheiros aeroespaciais em
portugal o que vocês vão fazer com todos
o desemprego é verdade o curso é um
curso muito recente e se há cinco anos
não havia nenhum engenheiro aeroespacial
formado tanto os alunos da primeira
fornada estava aqui perdedores neste ano
e quer acreditar do órgão engenheiro
ainda o fim deste primeiro ano das 35
dos 35 alunos que entrarem aeroespacial
novos desistiram do curso e mudaram só
para aumentar suas possibilidades de
empregabilidade no fim eu acho que caí
sky continuar e no quarteto em cy linde
ir mais longe se diga que revelou ser a
não seguir para a universidade técnica
do hotel que outro mundo
nessa altura porém entraram 300 alunos
contra os 35 entravam no aumento do
técnico leão três especializações contra
as duas que poderia tirar o técnico
fraco lá tem um avião que os alunos
poderão usar para fazer ensaios em vôo
estava a desenvolver a próxima geração
de simulador de vôo pilotos era um mundo
completamente diferente
foi lá que partirá em plenária da
simulação e de sistemas de detecção
encontrou na área especial
não é errado além de que está também um
dos maiores centros da agência espacial
européia que faz desenvolvimento
tecnológico
essa proximidade entre o eztec acumulado
fazia com conhecimento fluísse muito
rapidamente o que era muito ativa dos
alunos
esta é uma imagem uma foto que tirei na
altura a moca da estação espacial
internacional
este módulo em concreto foi a
contribuição da europa
essa estação e eu tive a sorte de vê lo
a ser construídos enquanto tyson gay uma
empresa romã em breve e eu sentia que
era isso mesmo que agora gostava de
fazer
os aviões passado a história é verdade
que analisará esta seria minha vida os
cães salvaram sempre para mais longe da
ilha
o técnico adepto não foi curada
holandesa e depois para amanhã
durante este período portugal tornou se
membro da agência espacial européia no
ano 2000 mais ou menos a meio do
percurso
isso permite que durante essa altura as
empresas começassem a surgir no nosso
país então a dada altura uma delas é o
dom para voltar a portugal e uma decisão
talvez difícil em cima da mesa continua
numa empresa com milhares de
trabalhadores ou seja o número dois de
uma empresa em portugal
não tive dúvida até para portugal entrar
após passos não é sempre motivador
porque nós passamos anos e anos e anos a
desenvolver a tecnologia sem nunca foi
aplicada na realidade é que isso foi
principalmente um dos fatores que em
2006 fez nos juntar outros colegas e
fundaram a nossa própria empresa
aeroespacial em portugal as piores e os
dois principais objetivos o primeiro
continuar a desenvolver tecnologia
aeroespacial e fazer tudo para vê lo a
funcionar na realidade e depois trazer
essa tecnologia e aplicar o no mundo
caiu embaixo da terra
incluíram na cadeia do word é nacional e
foi aí que decidimos aguardar o mercado
os dramas
nós desenvolvemos desde 2006 nós
próprios dons tudo integralmente fitness
knox a estrutura do sistema de 900
controla e outros automáticos tudo entre
a estação do sol e temos vindo a incluir
em vários setores e hoje vou falar que
só o dom que o setor vitícola no próximo
vídeo vamos mostrar um vídeo filmado em
um vídeo filmado sobre uma das zonas
mais bonitas do país que o alto douro
vinhateiro e com nosso avião particular
voltou completamente forma torna eu vou
um bufo que é desenhado propósito pode
recolher e fotografia aérea sempre com a
mesma resolução
essa fotografia depois passava e obtemos
ortofotomapas nossa função que usamos
para produzir cartografia da resolução
também e modelos tridimensionais do
terreno que serve por exemplo para
implantação de linha nova e para prover
os homens de risco para deslizamentos do
filme quando usamos uma câmera que
recolhe mais do menino do infravermelho
podemos usar essa informação para
infringir sobre o vigor das plantas em
vigor as portas primeiros a dar as
cartas em divino na prática reduz o
vigor da planta
hoje vamos ter aqui uma prática são duas
já explico é que verde está assinalado
nas zonas de maior vigor e famílias
donas de menores de gordo
estas na prática são duas imagens uma
tirada de satélite que são as imagens
mais atrás que em mais um jogo os
resultados porque a solução é uma
redução de 10 metros por pixel ea imagem
que nós conseguimos obter tem 10
cêntimos por pixel
com isto tem um domínio desta imagem
nós temos informação que é muito os
produtores na prática temos tanta
informação que não é eli sabiá às rochas
estradas casas as árvores
conseguimos através de um modelo
tridimensional da resolução conseguir
segmentar e separar o que é vinha do que
o chão e tudo aquilo que não interessa o
promotor está interessado em saber o
vigor da planta planta e é isso que nós
conseguimos utilizar o carro produtora
agora olhar para essa informação e gerir
essa informação eu sabia tipicamente
pode ser um problema no subsolo que não
é tão fértil ou porque ficou à frente de
uma casa e creditaram simplesmente o
crescimento vai ter oferta como do lado
da equipe esta têm exatamente os mesmos
tipos de vidas e de feridos e apresentar
o mesmo vigor o então pode ser algo
normal e ser um fungo uma doença eo
poderá ir lá atuar pode selecionar zonas
diferenciadas e aplicar fertilizantes
não é preciso fugir cidades onde é
preciso régua onde é preciso e permite
obter uma melhor gestão dos seus
recursos consegue otimizar o primeiro
o plano do ambiente todos ganhamos um
portal web que nós desenvolvemos esse
crime por este feito e que o torcedor
pode manipular a informação por exemplo
aqui eu seria o gado na informação que
continua e dividir em duas classes zona
mais rigorosamente grosa por exemplo se
desvie mar
só a zona spanta na hora amanhã e com
isso fazer por exemplo um vinho topo de
gama porque o vôo particular é muito boa
e eu saí já tem fila que é o vinho tem
que apanhar
outra coisa que conseguimos testar e
falhas com os modelos tridimensionais
nós vemos diferenças de altura e sabemos
que há ali uma zona com falhas
conseguimos dar essa informação número
de plantas até comprado as coordenadas
da canção em espanhol para estados
diretamente no aumento de produtividade
vamos falar agora rapidamente no outro
tema que lhe é muito querido também que
é bobagem interplanetária desculpas
implantar uma imagem
rezem do homem na lua neil armstrong que
tirou esta fotografia e aquilo que
muitas pessoas não sabem é que 30
segundos antes de entrar o ano com um
olhar para esta janela é preciso que o
piloto automático do do sistema
americano estava dirigido o módulo para
uma zona que tem uma cratera
eu também gostaria de futebol concluídos
acentuados e com rocha do tamanho de
carros e portanto teve que viajar na sua
mãe se e desviar o veículo para um sítio
seguro
tínhamos feito não só a primeira trazem
de uma meia lua mas é a primeira vez em
que fiz de tensão e desvio de obstáculos
o que eu tento fazer há três anos e fez
um sistema automático para fazer esta
detenção e desviar de obstáculos
inspecionar nesta imagem onde é que você
iria aterrar incra que não existe
dúvidas que era naquela zona de voo mais
plana suave que todos iriam evitar as
crateras as rochas as montanhas que eles
estão lá já não seria tão fácil e nem
ficar aqui mas tem mais
vou mostrar uma dimensão que é o
resultado de uma situação que nós
fizemos o nosso software que funciona
num computador específico e vai para o
espaço
o computador tem pesquisadores que são
piores do que os telemóveis que os
estúdios fox bons e que um desafio
porque o funcionário em tempo real e ela
trazem marcas disse esta parte mais
dinâmica e quando a pressão do
paraquedas eo veículo quer simplesmente
fugir do agito pára-quedas a estabilizar
ao longo de uma trajetória vertical
enquanto a próxima da superfície está
sempre a travar para reduzir a sua
sociedade e atingido o sol começa com
uma velocidade muito reduzida enquanto
10 e também fotografias com uma câmera
com o sistema de unidade e com isso
consegue tratar zonas de sombra de
texturas de livros e de rochas com essa
informação eu consegue saber quais são
as zonas seguras e zonas perigosas dessa
superfície e se dirigiam os bons na
perigosa como é o caso deste cenário
escolhe bola que é o melhor local para
trazem e passa informação pelo piloto
automático que trata de guiar o veículo
lá tudo isso tem que acontecer em menos
de 30 segundos
o próximo passo à frente foi despedido
faltou dizer que é uma coisa importante
é que nós já fizemos milhares de
simulações mesmo já disse mas com testes
que tivemos uma taxa de sucesso acima de
99 por cento o que é muito bom de
emissões ea agência espacial européia
pedindo só cai você já tem um software
funcionar num computador em tempo real
eu quero agora vêem mais reais e não
sintéticas como essas que vocês viram
aqui e pediram para montar um time que
está aqui em uma praia em que tem 2 mil
metros quadrados e fomos para lá diz
pesava 120 toneladas de rocha de forma
aleatória para aplicar um terreno que
seja mesmo um desafio para atacar
acidente aquilo que encontraríamos em
marte
o resultado deste ano
estamos neste momento de iniciar os
testes em vôo na próxima semana uma
reuniã o e evidenciar a cerca de mil
testes e ensaios assim semelhante àquela
de animação ou seja vira esperamos
comprovar até 7 99% também não podia
deixar de acabar sem feridos
esta situação que é uma das minhas
pistas preferidas e que escalará o nosso
lema de vida assafe disse que quem é
importante termos objetivos ter um focus
ea seleção foi feita por exemplo caiu de
260 anunciou ao mundo que um país
inteiro tenha ciúme com um objetivo
comum
outro levar um homem à lua em uma década
objetivas transmissão 11
sabia que ia ser difícil mas é um
desafio que eu não estava disposto a
enviar eu quis abraçar este desafio e
que ganhou
eu acho que se fizéssemos todos desta
forma
nossos objetivos mais ou menos
ambiciosos e vencermos o nosso melhor
seremos sempre bem sucedidos da bahia
[Aplausos]